la noche del jueves un nuevo tiroteo
masivo golpeó a eeuu un joven de 19 años
abrió fuego contra los trabajadores de
la sede de la compañía fedex en
indianápolis en el tiroteo el asaltante
asesinó a ocho personas e hirió a cinco
después se quitó la vida había trabajado
para la compañía y tenía dos
antecedentes policiales
el presidente joe biden volvió a mandar
un mensaje al senado pidiendo un mayor
control a las armas de fuego y que no se
acepte una violencia que causa 106
fallecidos cada día esto tiene que
terminar es una vergüenza nacional
el congreso tiene que dar un paso
adelante y actuar el senado tiene que
actuar nunca he dejado de apoyar la
prohibición de armas de asalto la
administración byd en busca que se
promulguen leyes que dificulten el porte
de armas como un refuerzo del sistema de
verificación de antecedentes la
prohibición de armas de guerra y
cargadores de alta capacidad
no hay dudas de que esta violencia debe
terminar estamos pensando en las
familias que han perdido a sus seres
queridos este fue el quinto tiroteo
múltiple de las últimas semanas y en lo
que va de año indianápolis ha sufrido
tres tiroteos masivos y de ira por
suárez
anoche indianápolis fue golpeada por el
flagelo de la violencia armada que ha
matado a demasiados en nuestra comunidad
y nuestro país la posesión de armas es
un asunto de polarización en eeuu donde
hay más de 400 millones de armas para
330 millones de personas en 2020 se
registró el mayor número de víctimas en
tiroteos cerca de 20.000 perdieron la
vida sin embargo existe un poderoso
lobby en torno a la posesión de armas
que llega hasta el partido republicano
quien se opone a una mayor regulación